so let's actually let's let's jump to
this the main actual
okay the main thing we wanted to talk
about yeah yeah
exclusive president trump threatens
federal action in violent
democrat-run cities town hall says
during an exclusive interview with town
hall from the white house tuesday
president trump warned his
administration will take action if
democratic mayors and governors can't
get crime under control
they are cities run by liberal democrats
we're now looking at having to do
something you know
we have to be asked to go into a city
like chicago which is so ridiculous
where they had like 68 shootings and 18
deaths over the weekend
it's not even comprehensible worse than
afghanistan worse than any war zone
nightmarish can you check off your bingo
cards now for tim paul saying the word
nightmare dystopia i have it i have it
yep on the right
there you go checked done there it is
we're supposed to be asked
she is supposed to call the mayor
lightfoot lori she's supposed to call
and say we need your help
we call her would you like to have us
come in and they don't want us and i say
what's going on
during the interview trump said police
in cities like chicago and new york new
york city aren't allowed to do their
jobs and are terrified of legal action
we are going to have to do something
very comprehensive it means sending
people
in it means sending people into clean up
there's a point at which we're
we're allowed to go in and that point is
rapidly being reached
there's a point at which we will have to
do it because we just have to do it for
the good of the country
when asked about what threshold must be
met before federal action is taken
the president said carnage and death is
his standard
i'm pretty sure we're past that yeah
chicago's
you know it's funny because chicago was
was the most dangerous city
in america for a while and then it it
started to get a little bit better
for for a little bit there for a couple
years
and man is it a war zone again it's
getting worse and it's getting worse
you know and and this makes a good point
like
the cops aren't allowed to do their job
for fear and they're terrified of legal
action
i i watched a video of um uh
nypd training of what they have to go
through
and they're they are now not allowed to
do most non-lethal tactics anymore
like leaning on their chest leaning on
their back sitting on them like
i i do i get the you know you don't want
people to kill
anybody but they're now riding between
not doing anything and the only means
which is pulling their gun when they're
in fear of their life which is
the last thing i want i don't want
people pulling guns i don't want them to
have to use
lethal force i think crowder was talking
about this like the use of chokeholds
is a is a less lethal tactic for the
escalation didn't he choke out one of
his
yeah he did let's not do that on this
show
like do you know you know kids would
play the pass out game
no remember that no i'm not gonna
explain what they do but they purposely
made themselves pass out they would go
in like
in grade school they'd be like and then
you'd they'd fall over and everyone
would laugh
is this another one of those tick tock
challenges i wouldn't be surprised
but this is back when i was a kid oh
okay yeah it's basically you know how to
do a chokehold
the original tick-tock real life yeah
yeah yeah well they were doing that the
skull breaker challenge yeah
make someone jump and then knock jeez
man these kids are nuts
but anyway trump sending in the troops
you see in oregon
as soon as the feds came in to defend
federal jurisdiction the federal
courthouse
trump's occupying army that's what they
said yeah this annoys me because
they they've been it's always this back
and forth game they keep
going with trump they're like how come
he's not doing anything
and he's like i'll do something if you
want me to and they're like uh how dare
he try to do
something at all and he's like okay i'll
back off how dare he
say he's gonna back off like and it's
just like back and forth and back and
forth and back and forth
i hope american people can see this oh i
think they can man
they're like fairly certain donald
donald trump says i'm gonna go in
and we're gonna clean up kovid we got
serious problems and they're like you
have no right
you have no authority over the states
you can't tell them what to do
right you can't shut them down now
they're like it's all trump's fault
how dare he not shut all the states down
how dare you it's the weirdest thing
that new york is the problem
and new jersey and new jersey both of
them those those are the big problems
yep
and and what why are they blaming trump
for this yeah why
wh he can't control what the governor's
did and the governor's locked down
right and then they did a bunch of other
really bad stuff and while they were
doing it they were
they had their their chins high they
said
i dare you to do something trump i dare
you
i'm like bring it on you know what man
i think we're all his fault i don't
think people realize
exactly where we are in terms of the
dramatic escalation
i think yeah i don't was watching oh
yeah
knowing with uh with the nicholas cage
we're watching knowing yeah
and it's like uh it's out it's a 20 year
old movie so spoiler alert
uh the planet blows up i don't know
there's like a solar flare
but there's a scene at the end of the
movie where the solar flare hits
and it shows you like an overview of new
york with a fire sweeping across
you could be standing in like battery
park at south
southern tip of manhattan island and not
realize that in one minute a giant wave
of fire was going to blow you up
yeah and so people are standing there
just doing nothing might you know not
realizing that a minute
they're gone i think that's where we're
at i think i think the figurative meteor
has slammed into the planet already
and the wave is now sweeping across but
people don't realize how bad it already
is
that's a good point i think we're really
close to donald trump i think
i think we're closer than closer to
presidential directive 51 we've ever
been to i think there's a really good
possibility
come november trump is gonna was that
bush who put that
into place yeah yeah i was like you know
i think it was an o7 okay could be wrong
but uh i think we're really close to
trump enacting presidential director 51
which would reform the government
and create a continuity coordinator and
dissolve and restructure it
due to catastrophe i mean at this point
i wouldn't be surprised if most of the
country was like oh
finally well so
with the threat of war with the chaos in
the streets
when i mention i mentioned this several
times the cdc having his employees
yeah if the cdc declares racism a public
health crisis
what does that mean i have no idea are
we gonna get to the point
where i've mentioned before like you
must destroy your copy of the
constitution
because it was made by racists and
racism is killing people
you don't want to kill people do you
well then you can't support racism right
that's funny i was listening
to a speech from obama and he said
if anyone has any doubts that america
isn't amazing that and you can do
anything
that our forefathers didn't didn't make
this happen let there be no more doubts
yeah and it's like that wasn't that long
ago right like where where did that
happen
what like imagine if if trump said that
right now
imagine if trump said that right now
people would flip yep
and it's like we had two what's the
difference it's true
two terms of obama right that means
people voted for trump
voted for obama people that voted for
obama then went on to vote for trump
that's true but they're all racists
i i look at what's going on and i think
there's a hurricane in bruin man yeah
it's it's it's it's it's made landfall
and people are sitting there thinking
i'm just going to sit back and wait for
this to all
let's do another shot of the dead
reference the zombie apocalypse is here
they're they're romping about they're
they're smashing people they're biting
and killing
and you get these people who are like
let's go to the the winchester and wait
for this to all blow over
and so they they go to the pub and think
the zombies won't come zombies do come
and so i think it's substantially worse
than people realize
yeah when you see you know what's going
on with
uh with the rioting with kovid let's
talk about
the economy the stocks are skyrocketing
right now
so i i have the only the only stock i
have is square
actually this was a funny little
disclaimer we did at the beginning of
the joe rogan podcast with dorsey i was
like full disclosure i've got
a small amount of square stock because
he's a ceo it is it is doubled
doubled wow in a couple like two months
doubled that's insane i wonder if these
are death throws
hmm yeah so so listen mortgage uh
housing payments
were missed 32 percent people aren't
paying rent people aren't working
yet jobs are coming back and all that
stuff but i've mentioned this before man
when the economy was just stopped by all
these governors
not by trump the train doesn't just go
boop and stop
every car starts ramming into the next
and all that energy gets transferred and
the whole train
starts flipping over and crashing off
the tracks you can't just stop it
so the damage that's hit the tax base
it's funny new york city says we're
going to defund the police by a billion
dollars
you know what i think they needed that
money they needed that money elsewhere
bingo
the trains are collapsing sure we'll
defund it because we were so broke
and and the blizzard's going thank you
thank you for giving me an excuse we are
in serious trouble yep
and people are fleeing i went on a
zillow.com real estate website
in the past 30 days new york city 7 600
entries for real estate for sale wow do
you know how much sale do you know how
many
do you know how many listings there were
in the two months before
hundred oh five thousand in the chat it
went
i'm sorry did you say seven hundred and
fifty thousand seven thousand six oh
seven thousand okay okay so
so listen it didn't go up that much then
in two months
you had about five thousand listings
yeah
the next month which was last month 7
600.
oh that's a pretty big bump what
happened in last month that's a lot of
people tripled yeah the amount of
listings it's not just
it's condos okay residences oh sure sure
yeah
it's it's it's the collapse man a lot of
these people probably already left
they're no longer paying taxes to the
city or the state now they're selling
their property good luck selling it the
prices are going to collapse
when that happens the tax base has
already been eroding they were
already in trouble that's just in new
york
you know what they're gonna they're
gonna rename the city new flint
new flint yep it's gonna be like detroit
yep
they're not gonna be able to support
clean well i think new york's water
source is actually really clean and
they're lucky because it comes from up
north in the
you know mountains and stuff yeah that's
true but new york was already hurting
then covet happened then the riots
happened
the economy is is is in is in really bad
shape more than anyone realizes
now trump i believe is obligated to be
optimistic
because if he came out and said it's
worse than you realize people would
panic
that would lead to more destruction good
point i think trump's best he can do is
tout the good numbers but what does the
media do
no matter what happens i know it's bad
it's like
you know record-breaking jobs month and
they go
they're like this is actually you know
not true because these are furloughs and
trump's just lying it's like
can you can you let people have this one
can you get can you take the win can you
let the
american people think that at least
because who cares about trump
at this moment let the american people
have a little bit of hope confidence how
about that confidence start working yes
exactly recover but i'm going to be
honest and i'm not trying to say this to
be
a naysayer or pessimistic oh man but
look at
go ahead say it just say it
mortgage-backed securities they're
there you're gonna say i'm saying it oh
okay yeah people aren't paying their
mortgages
what happens when the when the mortgages
go delinquent the banks default on their
on the loan's default yep then then the
bank's default
and we get 07 again that's true so guess
whose fault it's going to
be in the mainstream media and guess who
they're going to well no no no no i
think it's coveted i think there's
nothing that could be done it's nobody's
fault
now we can blame the the democratic
governors for a lot of things
particularly putting coveted patients in
nursing homes
but now that they're demanding these
ridiculous restrictions
i gotta say man first and foremost don't
don't you get your health advice from
your doctor and nobody else period
nobody else but maybe trump is right
there was like a leaked memo where
apparently trump is saying we're gonna
have to learn to live with this
like covet is here we can't just stop
our
you know the economy has to function
that's true and maybe he's right
i mean this whole thing about people
being upset about masks cause
most people wear masks most people wear
masks
i don't mind wearing a mask there are
people who don't wear masks
high profile there are some people that
don't wear a mask that's very true
but for the most part nobody cares about
wearing a mask
we'll wear a mask if we need to trump
warm people want to work again
they need to get back to work period yep
we need to make it happen
but that ripple from when the meteor
dropped into that water
yeah that's the that damage from the
economy from from the initial covet
lockdown
you're right it's going to rip apart
everything it's going to
this is the craziest thing to me when i
see these activists posting things like
print money
and i'm just sitting here like that
whole thing listen listen
uh alyssa milano that's you you saw that
yeah i did
when she was like we are not going back
to school we just print money and give
it to people
there's no reasoning with her rage no
she's addicted to it you're right
and that idea of just not working
sitting back and printing money
leads to one thing the end of america
yeah yep
it's not an exaggeration it's not
hyperbolic to say no there's
if you just keep printing money and no
one produces you will have
hyperinflation
and this will have a profound
detrimental effect on the rest of the
planet
hyperinflation and no products to even
exactly
but nothing nothing will be worth
anything that's why the money becomes
worthless and what happened in venezuela
yeah that's exactly what happened in
venezuela what can you do with your
money
let's say someone gave you a million
bucks right now what would you do
now for now you could buy tesla i'd buy
a house i'd buy it
there's things you can do could you go
to an infinity pool on a rooftop bar
probably no you can't why not because
they're closed they're re-locking
everything down
that's a good point the point is that
these luxury items that gave the money
value in the first place
i'm pretty sure the million dollars i
could do it though i'm not convinced
i'm not convinced because it's a lot of
these people who have access to this are
are part of the anti-trump you know shut
it all down
train good point they're not they're
gonna be like what are you crazy
i'm not gonna risk grandma's life for
you now i'm sure they're a bunch of rich
people who know where to go and do their
thing you know what i mean
the point is a million dollars okay
maybe over the top if you had 100 bucks
could you go to the bar down the street
sit down have a pint you can't
nope so how much value does the money
have if services have been
erased it has less already less value
yeah so then when someone says i'll give
you a hundred bucks you go i can't even
do anything with a hundred bucks
yeah what am i gonna do buy a bag of
potatoes okay about 200 bucks
i guess i can get two bags of potatoes
right fine i'll take 200 bucks
the less the dollar can do the less
value it has it's it's it's as simple as
basic
understanding of reality if you had a
machine that could drive
it could be a boat a car or a plane
that's a valuable machine
especially if it's very safe that's got
to be worth hundreds of thousands of
dollars
you know look at it look at a regular
car versus a tesla the more versatile
the more
the more it can do the more valuable it
is that's a good point us dollar works
the same way
yep if you can't buy anything with it we
wh
we were trying to order skateboards yeah
a specific skateboard sold out
sold out can't get them yep so what it's
like if someone came to me and said
you know obviously need money for food
but there's a point i made before what
do you have food
what if what if you you work at a market
you have a bunch of excess food you
can't get rid of
because business has been slowed down
and someone comes says i'll give you a
hundred dollars to do you know a thing
you're gonna be like
i got food i don't know what i would do
with it everything's shut down i don't
drive anywhere
yeah i mean i guess i'll take it money's
money at a certain point if we lose
so right now people still have
confidence in the dollar so the dollar
will have value
but what happens in they're saying
they're saying it's gonna be another
nine or 12 months
of lockdown what happens in a year
of continued lockdown and then it gets
to the point where people start losing
confidence and they say
i mean i could take your dollars but i
can't really do anything with them so
i don't know looking at the death rates
the the whole
now no one's talking about the death
rates at all it's like
non-existent no one's talking about it
because they're really low no one's
dying anymore
yeah i mean yes it exists but
it's like the the one story like wow so
this one person died today of covid and
it's like
that's it one person like this isn't the
case fantastic
yeah because people can have it because
it's it's a like a regular coronavirus
like
the term coronavirus has been weaponized
now
it's craziness i think we're in trouble
and it almost feels like
there are people who are so dumb they
don't realize you have the choice
between
people are going to get sick and they're
going to die yeah and trump
or lock everyone in their homes and
everyone will die
worse and just strip everyone's
resources away and just
wither what do you die what do you do
about a person like alyssa milano
who doesn't realize it's like imagine
you you found somebody who was like
you know blind deaf and dumb and you
just and that there's like
totally incapable and you just put their
finger on a trigger for a nuclear bomb
you can't raise in with them they don't
know they're going to go
not knowing what the alyssa milano's got
tons of followers
she has no idea what she's talking about
but she's angry and she's firing off 50
cals in random direction
just print money print money and it's
like you're destroying everything stop
no because orange man is bad yep
that's what's gonna happen all these
people on twitter you know what man i i
it's like if i if i was uh
targeting a foreign country working for
a military whatever
you could not ask for a more perfect
outcome it's true to destabilize and
destroy your enemy you're absolutely
right
having a bunch of people demand the
government do nonsensical things that
destroy its own country
their own country and they're doing it
and there's no reasoning with them
because they're addicted to anger you're
absolutely right
how do we pull out of this talespin i
i'm trying to figure the answer right
every single day every single day i i've
tried to figure it out
thomas soul is an economist i watch
ever try to do a new interview every
single day that i don't i didn't watch
before
he he's an incredible smart incredibly
smart man that everyone needs to
go listen to i think we're close to the
point where we end up with
hardcore authoritarianism from the right
yeah but
knowing i mean i i i just i've been
diving into trump lately and i know the
type of person he is i don't think that
he wants that
i think he i think he believes in the
american
life the american freedom the american
way the dream of being an american
i think both sides are at a point where
there's no reconciliation
good point and both are going to demand
of their own faction the only way to
save
our country is to violently purge the
other side
that's a shame
the conversations i've had with people
i'm sure the conversations you've had
when you see children disowning their
parents parents signing their children
or whatever yeah
like how do we get past that if
i think november is going to be a hoot
so too man
i think that it's going to be it's i
mean i have to learn how to run
only not only november i think
going from this point to november it's
just going to get crazier and crazier
yeah dude this has been the craziest
year of my life hands down
yeah i'm pretty sure everyone everyone
everyone most people can say that
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 pm if
you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you